[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم حضر رئيس اللبناني ميشيل سليمان
من مخاطر الفراغ الرئاسي الذي يدخله لبنان
مع انتهاء فتره ولايه سليمان بنهايه يوم
السبت نتيجه فشل البرلمان في انتخاب رئيس
جديد للبلاد نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي المخاطر التي تواجه لبنان
الان بسبب دخوله حاله الفراغ
الرئاسي وما العوامل التي تتحكم في توافق
اللبنانيين على انتخاب رئيس جديد
لبلادهم غادر الرئيس اللبناني ميشيل
سليمان قصر بعبدا يوم السبت قبل ساعات من
انتهاء ولايته التي دامت ست سنوات وصلت
نهايتها دون ان يتمكن اللبنانيون من
اختيار خليفه له امر يضع لبنان مجددا امام
حاله فراغ رئاسي يحذر الكثيرون من
تداعياتها دون ان يتمكنوا من تقديم رؤيه
تخرج البلاد من
غياهبه الى فراغ جديد يستدعي تدخلا
اقليميا ودوليا ربما يتجه لبنان يغادر
سليمان القصر الرئاسي جاءه قبل ست سنوات
دون تسلم وتسليم ويغادر بمثل ما جاء لا
باس من خطاب وداع يلقيه ليذكر مواطنيه
وتحديدا ممثليهم في البرلمان اومن يقف
خلفهم بان ثمه ازمه في البلاد قد تؤدي الى
شلل في مؤسساتها كلها اجتمع البرلمان خمس
مرات وفشل في انتخاب رئيس جديد فل النصاب
تامن في البرلمان ولا التوافق خارجه اصبح
قريبا ما يعيد الى تاريخين كان الفراغ
الرئاسي فيهما مدخلا لتدخل خارجي مره في
مدينه الطائف باتفاق حمل اسم المدينه
السعوديه واخرى في العاصمه القطريه وجاءت
بسليمان
رئيسا دستوريا تتولى الحكومه الحاليه مهام
الرئيس لكن ذلك لا يحل تلقائيا المشكلات
الناجمه عن الفراغ الرئاسي فالعمل
التشريعي في البرلمان قد يتعرض للشلل وفقا
لمحللين وكذا الامر بالنسبه للسلطه
التنفيذيه في حال قاطعتها بعض الاطراف ما
يعني ت لا لمؤسسات الدوله
برمتها ياتي هذا بينما تواجه البلاد
تحديات غير مسبوقه في تاريخها المعاصر
ازمات اقتصاديه وسياسيه تتفاقم اضافه الى
تبعات الصراع في الجوار السوري على بيروت
انسانيا واقتصاديا وسياسيا لكن ما يسميه
البعض مجهولا تتجه اليه البلاد يقول اخرون
انه اصبح مالوفا لدى اللبنانيين
فالحكومة مددت ولايته ومن المحتمل ان تمدد
مره ثانيه كل ذلك يحدث بينما ينتظر
اللبنانيون التدخل الخارجي بل يستدعونه
اما المستجد فهو ان هذا التدخل لم يعد
ميسورا كالسابق فشان اللبناني تراجع من
حيث الاهميه لدى الاطراف الاقليميه
الفاعله في المنطقه يبقى رجل مثل عون ومن
يحالفه في انتظار التوافق الذي قد ياتي
ولا ياتي او اخر مثل سمير جعجع وقد ترشح
للرئاسه املا كما يقول مناصرو بتغيير
قواعد الترس يبحث هو الاخر ايضا ومعه
حلفائه عن حل لكن كلا الرجلين يظل وفقا
لمحللين مثل بقيه اللبنانيين ينظرون الى
الخارج وما قد ياتي به من توافقات اقليميه
ودوليه معنا في هذه الحلقه من بيروت محمد
المراد عضو المكتب السياسي في تيار
المستقبل وبسام هاشم القيادي في التيار
الوطني الحر اهلا بضيفنا نبدا بسيد المراد
ما هي المخاطر الان التي تهدد لبنان بسبب
الفراغ
الرئاسي لا شك ان مساله استحقاق انتخاب
رئاسه الجمهوريه له رمزيه وطنيه وله بعد
مؤسسي فموقع رئاسه الجمهوريه يعتبر الموقع
الاول في لبنان اي وله اهميته لا سما ان
هذا الموقع الذي يتراس او الذي يمارس هذه
الصلاحيات فيه هو من الطائفه المسيحيه
الكريمه وبالتالي يعبر عن خاصيه ليست
موجوده حتى في المحيط وان عمليه ال
الافشات التي حصلت كما ذكرتم في التقرير
لاكثر من خمس مرات ومعروف من القاسي
والداني من الداخل والخارج من الذي قام
بعمليه افشال مجلس النواب بانتخاب رئيس
جديد للجمهوريه اللبنانيه وهو اصبح واضح
بقرار من حزب الله وايضا بمشاركه من
الطيار الوطني الحر على قاعده غير معلومه
وعلى قاعده غير معروفه فبالتالي ان افش
هذا ان عمليه الافشات هذه حقيقه ترتب على
النواب الذين امتنعوا عن قصد واعتقد عن
قصد بحسب المسار الذي تمت على اساسه
الامور يتحملون هؤلاء النواب المسؤوليه
الكبرى كما
يتحمل القاده السياسيون
الذين الذين يمشون على هداهم وعلى وعلى
طريقهم وبالتالي لا شك ان لبنان كما ذكرتم
ايضا هناك كثير من المخاطر التي يمكن ان
تنتظره نتيجه ذلك القصور الذي تحقق بكل
اسف بعدم انجاز هذا الاستحقاق المهم
والاساسي في لبنان وانا اعتقد ان الم
المروع هو اكبر من ذلك بكثير نعم قبل قبل
قبل يعني عفوا بعد اذنك قبل ان ندخل في
تفاصيل المشروع الذي تريد الحديث
عنه اشرت الى مخاطر معينه ولكن اذا اردنا
سيد بسام الهاشم ان ان نفصل اكثر المخاطر
الحقيقيه او المحتمله هل لديكم وعي
بذلك يعني اسمح لي
بالاساس يعني صحح بعض ما قاله الاستاذ
الكريم حول انه عمليه التعطيل
لا اسمح لي سيد هاشم يعني بعد اذنك
الاشكالات اللبنانيه اللبنانيه كثيره واذا
دخلنا في سراديب لن نخرج منها اذا اردنا
ان نركز فقط لا بعد اذنك فقط اذا اردنا ان
نركز على مخاطر مخاطر بعد اذنك فقط اذا
اردنا ان نركز على مخاطر على راسي بس تقول
انا انا اعترض على القراءه يل ت بالطبع هو
هو سيعترض على قراءتك هذا بالتاكيد والا
ما كان في 14 اذار وث اذار هذا بالتاكيد
يعني اذا اردنا ان ان ناخذ منكم ان كان
لديكم تصور لمخاطر تهدد البلد بسبب الفراغ
الرئاسي يا سيدي انا بعتقد انه ال سواء
كان في رئيس او ما في رئيس المخاطر التي
تهدد البلد يعني هي هي ذاتها ما راح تختلف
اي اساسا يعني مع يعني شغور مركز رئيس
الجمهوريه نتيجه تعذر انتخاب بديل عنه
الدستور لحظ يعني بالماده 62 منه
انه انه في حال شغور مركز الرئاسي يعني
يقوم باعمال رئيس الجمهوريه مجلس الوزراء
مجتمعا ومجلس الوزراء مجتمعا ممثلين فيه
كل الطوائف المسيحيين والمسلمين على
اختلاف انتماءاتهم
المذهبيه على قاعده المناصفه الاسلاميه
المسيحيه
وبالنسب النسبيه على مختلف التلوين
الطائفيه ما في اي خطر يعني انه رح انه
ممكن ينتج عن هذا الوضع لا سمح الله ل
تعريض امن البلد الخطر هالشيء هذا منه
وارد الحقيقه اللي حاصل انه ال البلد يعني
بكل اسف النظام الانتخابي ي اعتمد
بالطائف يعني نظام انتخابي مثل كانه انعمل
كان في قوه قوه خارجيه هي يعني
مولج رعايه لبنم بك للاسف يعني مارست عليه
الوصايه وكانت هي توزع الادوار وبالتالي
يعني كانت تضمن دائما انه عند الاستحقاق
انه
يتم يتم انتخاب رئيس جديد اليوم من بعد
خروج هي المره الثانيه يعني نجرب حظ من
بعد خروج القوات الوصيه يعني القوات
السوريه
الشقيقه من من لبنان للمره التاليه للمره
الثانيه يتبين تعذر انجاز الاستح
الاستحقاق الرئاسي بموعده نعم ولكن سيد
الهاشم اشرت الى نقطه مهمه سيد الهاشم بعد
اذنك اشرت الى ان الحكومه بتلوي الدينيه
والمذهبيه المختلفه يفترض ان تسير الامور
ولكن هنا اريد ان اسال سيد مراد في في ضوء
التجاذب السياسي القائم الان وحتى التوتر
كيف يمكن لحكومه بهذه التلوين ان
تضمن عمل حكومي وفي نفس الوقت تعويض مؤسسه
رئاسه
شاغره سيدي الكريم على خلاف ما ذكر
الاستاذ هاشم و على خلاف قناعاته لانه كان
التيار الوطني الحر من الدعاه الى
المحافظه على حقوق المسيحيين وانا افاجئ
بهذا النوع من الكلام ولا ان كان من
الناحيه من الناحيه الدستوريه الماده 62
صحيح انها توكل صلاحيات رئيس الجمهوريه
الى مجلس الوزراء في حال الشغور انما الا
انما الامر خلاف ذلك من من ناحيه منظور
التيار الوطني الحر لهذا الموضوع فضلا عن
موقف البطر قصف البطرك الراعي وال القاده
المسيحيون في لبنان الذين يصرون ويعتبرون
ان
عمليه عمليه عدم الجديه في في التعاطي مع
هذا الاستحقاق فهو يعتبر جريمه بحق هذا
الموقع فضلا عن ما يشكل من تهديد وتعريض
لموقع رئاسه الجمهوريه اما النقطه الثانيه
التي اشار اليها ونحن لا نامل ان يكون
لبنان قد يتعرض للخطر ولكن هناك سوابق
حصلت في السابق وكما تعلمون انه كيف تم
انتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه ميشيل السيمان بعام
2008 ونعرف تماما عمليه غزو بيروت التي
حصلت في تلك السنه والتي ادت ما ادت اليه
والتي لا نزال لا نزال نعيش تداعياتها
فبالتالي انا كنت امل من الاستاذ ان يعالج
الموضوع بطريقه اخرى لان بذلك يشكل حقيقه
الحفاظ على وحده البلد بشكل دون ان ننظر
الى مصالحنا
الشخصيه مساله سيد مراد اعود الى سيد بسام
الهاشم هل هناك خوف سيد الهاشم من ان
المساله تتجاوز الفراغ في مؤسسه الرئاسه
الى نوع من الشلل لان اذا كان منصب الرئيس
فارغ اسمح لي فقط اكمل اسمحلي اسمح لي فقط
اكمل السؤال اسمح لي الله يخليك اذا كان
هناك مشكل في مؤسسه الرئاسه والحكومه غير
متجانسه هل هناك خوف من شلل كامل في
مؤسسات الدوله هل هذا الخطر
قائم يعني هناك هناك احتمال يعني كل هذا
يعني كل هذا يعني سوف يتقرر في ضوء ما سوف
تتخذه من مواقف مختلف الكتل النيابيه
المعنيه ولكن اسمح لي بالعوده الى ما تفضل
يعني لمناقشه شيء قالوا ما معقوله انه اول
مره ما سمحت لي اني اعلق على الشيء اللي
تفضل فيه وثاني مره بدي اعلق واقع الحال
يعني عم يجي بكلامه الاستاذ الكريم عم
بيجي بهمنا مثل كانه نحن يلي جينا عطلنا
عطلنا شو اسمه العمليه الدستوريه هذا
الكلام هذا منه صحيح جينا باول جلسه عقدت
جينا نحن نزلنا نحن وحلفائنا نزلنا على
مجلس النواب واملنا النصاب الدستوري املنا
النصاب الدستوري وصار في تصويت مين ترشح
ترشح السيد سمير جعجع
وترشح يمثل فريق 14
ادار وترشح السيد ري حلو من قبل وليد
جبلات وبالنسبه الفريق ثماني قدر والتيار
الوطني الحر ما في منهم مرشح واقع الحال
انه سمير جعجع اخذ 48 صوت اري حله اخذ 16
صوت وفي ست اصوات
صوتوا يعني لناس يعني مسؤول سمير جاج ولكن
ولكن سيد الهاشم سمحي سي
الذ لو س يا سيد هاشم هذه القصه الصه معفه
خليني اخذ الخلاصه منها خليني اخذ الخلاصه
من الخلاصه عفوا عفوا تضل القانون الدستور
يقول انه في الدوره الاولى مفروض حتى يتم
انتخاب الرئيس انه يجمع ثلثين اصوات
المجلس كحد ادنى وبدوره الثانيه خم يعني
النص زائد واحد يعني 5 صوت اقصى ما جمع
سمير جع جع 48 صوت عف يا سيد هاشم اطي
خلاصه انت بدك الخلاصه يا سيد هاشم هذه
القصه
كلها القصه نا عرفها هذ القصه كلنا عرفها
تفضل اطنا الخلاصه نحن سعينا وما زلنا
نسعى الى انتخاب رئيس يحقق اجماع
اللبنانيين المجلس النيابي يلي يلي افرزته
انتخابات 2009 اللي مازال هو بعد ما جدل
نفسه هو
اليوم من اين يؤتى من اين يؤتى برئيس عليه
اجماع في لبنان حتى م حتى م الذي يريد ان
يكون حتى ميشيل عون الذي يريد ان يكون محل
توافق هو طرف يعني هو طرف في النهايه ولا
يمكن ان يكون رئيس اسمحلي اسمحلي ان اعود
الى السيد مراد اسمحلي ان اعود سيد مراد
بس نحن لم نرضى برئيس من النوعيه اللي اجت
معنا مره الماضيه يعني بقيت ست سنين شعور
حقيقه هذه هي المشكله سيد مراد سيد الهاشم
البعض يتهم بانكم تريدون اس اسم اسم سش مع
مع الرئيس سعد الحريري وتيار المستقبل
وهذا الحوار واع والامل كبير انه يوصل
لخواتيم بوقت ار يعني البعض يتهم بانكم
تريدون رئيسا على مقاسكم والا فلا رئيس
اما ان ياتي رئيس كما نريده نحن والا
فليبقى لبنان بدون رئيس هذا هو الاتهام
الموجه اليكم لا يا سيده بنجر بنفهم نحن
كيف عم بتصير الامور ولا بدنا هيك نقصف
بالاتهامات هيك
لنعود الى سيد مراد لنعود الى سيد مراد
لان هذا الاتهام يوجه اليكم من قبل فريق
14 اذار بالدرجه الاولى انكم تريدون رئيس
على مقاسكم وبمواصفات التي تعجب حزب الله
وتعبس لنسم ج اذ 48 صوت حد الاقصى تبع يا
سيد الهاشم بعد اذنك نسمع وجهه نظر السيد
المراد سيدي الكريم اولا الذي يريد المقاس
على
قياسه امر واضح يعني وواضح من كلام
الاستاذ هاشم بانه اما ان يكون الجنرال
عون هو رئيس للجمهوريه او لا انتخابات
لرئاسه الجمهوريه وهذا امر ثبت من خلال
الممارسه على كل حال نحن الذي نريد ان
نؤكد عليه بان استحقاق هذا الاستحقاق وهذا
ما نخشاه الحقيقه لاننا تعودنا على تلك
الاساليب والمناورات التي ايه يكون بعض
البعض من هذا الفريق وان الاكثر خطوره في
هذه العمليه هو ان حزب الله قد يرى اليوم
ليس من مصلحته ان تجرى انتخابات لرئاسه
الجمهوريه لانه لديه مصالح واهتمامات اخرى
سواء التوغل في سوريا او ان ياتي واليوم
الحقيقه من المفاجئ ان يصدر عن احد مسؤولي
الشيخ نبلسي تصريح على كبير على قدر كبير
من الخطوره لجهه ضرب المناصفه وجهه ضرب
اتفاق الطائف وجهه ضرب المث
الو فالذي فالذي فالذي ارجوك استاذ ارجوك
فالذي يدعو
اليوم من جهه معينه ال الى مؤتمر
تاوك هو لم
يقاطع ارجوك ارجوك دعني دعني اكمل لانني
لم اقا
ما صدر اليوم عن احد مسؤولي حزب الله في
هذا الموضوع هو مؤشر على قدر كبير من
الخطوره ب
حال مستقبل هناك حوار هناك حوار مفتوح مع
التيار الوطني الحر وانه قد انتج حكومه
ولكن موضوع رئاسه الجمهوريه نحن موقفنا ك
14 ادار موقف موحد واض
نحن مرشحنا من 14 اار وكل ما من شانه ان
يحافظ على المسيحيين وما يقوله المسيحيون
في موضوع استحقاق رئاسه الجمهوريه فتيار
المستقبل مع اسمحلي سيد مرا اسمحلي سيد
مراد اسمحلي السيد على كل من يتابع هذا
الحوار يدرك يدرك تماما لماذا فشل
اللبنانيون في التوصل الى
رئيس اسمحلي البرنامج نم مصغر لماذا فشل
اللبنانيون في التوصل الى رئيس على كل هذا
بين قوسين انا فل ب اللبناني وبعض المس
اسمحلي اسمح لي سيد مراد اسمح لي سيد مراد
واسمح لي سيد هاشم سؤال اخير ساتو به لكل
منكما ابدا بالسيد بسام الهاشم هناك حديث
متواتر وباستمرار لم يعد لم يعد سرا بانه
طالما لا يوجد اتفاق اقليمي واتفاق دولي
على الرئيس اللبنانيون لن يتمكنوا من
اختيار رئيس ههذا الدرجه الى هذه الدرجه
وصلت هشاشه الدوله في لبنان الى هذا
الحد نحن شخصيا بالتيار الوطني الحر
العماد عون يراهن كثيرا ويامل خير من
الحوار العميق والجدي اللي قايم مع الرئيس
سعد الحريري خلافا للشيء اللي عم تفضل فيه
الاستاذ مراد نحن فايتين بحوار مع شريكنا
بالوطن ونحن بتامل انه شريكنا بالوطن يعني
بوقت قريب انه يكون توصل لتجاوز الظروف
اللي عم بتحول دون تمكنه من الخروج
بالاتفاق الحياء الى حي ز النور هذا هو
رهاننا ونتامل انه الناس اللي ماشيين معه
واللي هم عم دعوا الحرص على مصالح
المسيحيين وتمثيلهم معلش نحن اولى بمعرفه
مين وين مصلحه المسيحيين وكيف ضمان بقائهم
نتامل منهم انه يكونوا حد الرئيس سعد
الحريري ويساعده
بالتوصل بتسهيل التوصل الى حل لانه ما في
خلاص للبنان الا بتوافق المكون السني
والمكون الشيعي والمكون المسيحي لن يكون
لبنان لا يمكن ان يكون ان يقوم بتفاهمات
ثنائيه نعم واضح لنسمع لنسمع وجهه نظر
لنسمع وجهه نظر الان سيد مراد في في هذه
المساله التوافق الاقليمي
والدوله لا لا شك ان موضوع
ال لا لا يمكن ان ننكر الدور العربي
والدور الاقليمي والدولي في مساله في
المساله اللبنانيه او في مساله الداخل
اللبناني ولا سما
موضوع كموضوع مهم بما يتعلق برئاسه
الجمهوريه لكن هذا لا يعني على الاطلاق ان
على اللبنانيين ان يدركوا ان يدركوا حقيقه
ما هم فيه ولا سما ان بعضهم يفتش عن
مصالحه اكثر ما يفتش عن مصلحه وطن بكل
الحال الحوار مع التيار الوطني الحر ليس
الا مفتوحا من قبل الرئيس سعد الحريري
وتيار المستقبل وقد تحقق جزء كبير في هذا
المجال ولكن لا يعني ان الحوار من اجل ان
ان يؤتى بجنرال عون رئيسا للجمهوريه وانا
اقول ما يخيفني ويخيف اللبنانيين ان حزب
الله له اجنده معينه من قبل ايران فيما
يتعلق باستحقاق رئاسه الجمهوريه وان له
مصلحه اكيده في في تهميش مؤ الدوله
اللبنانيه ولا سيما موقع رئاسه الجمهوريه
شرا شكرا لك سيد محمد المراد عضو المكتب
السياسي في تيار المستقبل شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا بسام الهاشم القيادي في التيار
التيار الوطني الحر بهذا مشاهدينا نكون قد
وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه التي نعتذر عن
تاخرها عن موعدها المعتاد نلتقي باذن الله
في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد
استودعكم
الله
[موسيقى]
ا